[Applause]
[Music]
oh
you know what i'm talking about is low
key
thank you very much firstly i would like
you to make some noise for the sisters
doing the sign language right now
now when i say free free i want you to
say
palestine so loud that they hear you
in the israeli embassy no
i want you to say palestine so loud that
they hear you in your foots
no i want you to say palestine so now
that they hear you in the headset are
you with me free
free free
now israel has bombed the media tower in
heza and you know why
because it wants to hide its crimes
and the camera being pointed back at it
but you know how to stop
it you can stop it 100 thousand people
here
every single one of you tweet right
now post on your facebook post on your
instagram
crush the algorithm keep showing them
the truth of what israel has done to the
palestinian people
and others that they border with too
we have seen we have seen the call
responded to
by dock workers in italy they have
refused
to load weapons due for israel
and to ship to use against palestinians
i am calling to all of the unions in
this country the dock workers refuse
to load the weapons i am calling
to the people that work in the factories
you have 10 different sets for elbit
systems
the israeli arms company in this country
refuse to build those weapons
of war refuse
to complain refuse to
complain refuse to complain
refuse to complain refuse
to complain refuse to comply
refuse to complain
so when i say lovely saying i want you
to stay alone with god
are you with me
[Applause]
[Music]
he should feel fear the old live through
us and guarantee the children will
care criminal not invincible and you
know it
some of those simulators still sitting
in their stomach
you may not feel us with you when you
listen to our poems
but you inspire
thank you very much